استبدال مفصل الركبه واحده من اكثر جراحات
العظام شيوعا حول العالم يتم اجرائها بشكل
اساسي على الاشخاص الذين تبلغ اعمارهم 60
عاما او اكثر وهي عمليه يستبدل فيها بعض
او كل مفصل الثالث بموادم صناعيه عندما
تفشل الحلول الاخرى في معالجه خشونه
الركبه
بحلول عام 20 30 من المتوقع ان ينمو
اجمالي جراحات استبدال مفاصل الركبه في
الولايات المتحده بنسبه اكثر من 670% اي
ما يصل الى ثلاثه ونصف مليون اجراء سنويا
ستون بالمئه من عمليات الركبه يتم اجرائها
على النساء
85% من تلك العمليات يستمر اثرها لمده 20
عاما بشرط الالتزام بالتمارين وتوصيات
لعلاج الطبيعي المصابها عام 2020 تصدرت
سويسرا والمنظمه التعاون الاقتصادي
والتنميه في اجراء عمليه استبدال للركبه
او تقويم العظام حول نفس الركبه
حيث بلغ عدد تلك الجراحات 260 جراحه لكل
مئه الف سنه